blablabla darf ich jetzt gar nicht mehr
hingehen ich möchte es auch nicht dass
als nix passiert ja das zum thema das
soll nichts explodieren
hallo ihr lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen endlich mal gehört zu einer
neuen folge von minecraft guide und zwar
ist der minecraft eine serie wo ich euch
drei dinge zeige die ihr eventuell noch
nicht über minecraft wusste das tut mir
zwar leid das letzte serie
beziehungsweise letzte folge schon sehr
lange her ist er hat einfach vergessen
dass diese serie noch gibt aber ihr
könnt ihr einfach das video bewerten
wenn es euch gefällt und ihr mehr davon
möchte und dass es auch ein ansporn für
mich diese serie weiter laufen zu lassen
ich sehe was euch wirklich so gefällt
und ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt
erst direkt an mit der ersten sache die
eventuell noch nicht wusste was mir
selber noch ein bisschen geheuer ist
weil ich noch einmal richtig hingekriegt
habe aber es wird laut internet laut
seriöse internet quellen bestätigt und
zwar wenn wir ein schaf nehmen und das
sieben mal schlagen 4567 nun eine schere
nehmen mit beiden seiten da draufklicken
gibt es die möglichkeit dass man fünf
wolle bekommt das waren jetzt erstmal
nur drei aber wir ich habe ein paar
scharfes bohren lassen damit wir das ein
bisschen probieren das jetzt 45 67
so erzielen wir die scheren und jetzt
will ich mit beiden tasten also mit
linksklick und rechtsweg draufmachen
waren wieder nur 3 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
zack sind zwei mal schauen wie es heute
noch hinkriegen
1 2 3 4 5 6 7
so stelle ich erst mal hin ganz ruhig
sagt da das sind schon mal vier das ist
schon mal mehr also es ist bisher
bestätigt dass es auch wirklich klappt
47 noch nicht alles kaputt hier wieder
so das waren 3 das ist schade das ist
nicht die anzahl ich erreichen wollte
aber wir haben einmal schon mal vier
wolle gekriegt und das ja auch schon mal
gut 1 2 3 4 5 6 schnell die angeblich
wieder zu bauen
ok dann habe ich dich hier das war nur
zwei so ich versuche noch einmal an
diese dem hier der deckel ist noch nicht
ausgewachsen 1234
das waren auch vier also man kriegt auf
jeden fall mehr wolle raus wenn ihr das
7 x schlag und dann einfach mit der
schere mit beiden tasten drauf klickt
allerdings ist das sehr sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass es klappt weil
ganz einfach eine zwanzigste sekunde
dazwischen liegt als es darf nicht mehr
als eine 20 sekunde dazwischen liegen
dabei ist ich habe es zweimal geschafft
zweimal von sieben mal
und ja also das war auf jeden fall
erstmal die erste sache die ich euch
zeigen wollte
so kommen wir auch direkt zum zweiten
sache die ich euch zeigen wollte und
zwar haben sich ja manche leute manchmal
gefragt so wenn man in einem haus ist
zum beispiel und draußen und report
steht vom fenster kann der dann nicht
auch so explodieren weil manchen filmen
oder musik videos ist es natürlich so
dargestellt ist allerdings nicht so im
gegensatz zum echten leben wo vielleicht
räuber euch trotzdem sehen können sehen
euch creeper und et cetera nicht durchs
fenster und jetzt denken wahrscheinlich
einige hey du bist doch ein gelber
deswegen sehe ich nicht nein auch wenn
ich in den survival mode gehen sehen
mich die kripo nicht die skelette nicht
und auch die zombies licht das passiert
erst wenn ich ein glas oft mache dann
kommen die alle an und wollen mich ab
schießen und töten und blogger bleibe da
will ich jetzt gar nicht mehr hingehen
ich möchte es auch nicht in das halt nix
passiert
ja das zum thema das soll nichts
explodieren aber das war auf jeden fall
erstmal die zweite sache die ihr
wahrscheinlich noch nicht wusste und ich
sollte jetzt mal ganz schnell abholen so
und herzlich willkommen nun zur dritten
sache die er eventuell noch nicht
wusstet und zwar wenn ich an mit einem
boot zum beispiel gegen diese wolle da
hinten fahrer einfach ganz ganz schnell
gegen fahre ich sollte doch ein witz
beschleunigen jetzt mein boot kaputt das
hat ein wenig gedauert weil ich
natürlich sehr sehr langsam war
allerdings wenn ich das gleiche den
gleichen das gleiche prozedere gegen
soul cent wiederhole passiert gar nix
also ich fahre einfach nur gegen das ist
eine eigenschaft von cent egal mit
welcher power ich dagegen fahrer da
passiert nichts wenn ich allerdings mit
dem boden gegen den steine zum beispiel
gegen fahrer geht es kaputt also bei
source and besteht die möglichkeit bzw
das heißt besteht die möglichkeit auf
jeden fall geht euro dort nicht kaputt
das heißt wenn ihr euch in einem boot
strecke macht von einem haus man dann
zum beispiel macht an die enden sony
center krediten oder gegen gefahren und
dann einfach aussteigen so hey ich gehe
zu meinem kumpel rüber und versuchte man
seinem dorf hey da muss ich gar nicht
abbremsen geht so einfach aus und jetzt
wieder zurück und hey und der andere typ
von euch das dann eventuell nicht
mitgemacht und hat nicht dieses video
geschaut und da geht dann einfach kaputt
ist natürlich nicht so schön
ja das war die letzte sache ich würde
mich wie immer freuen wenn ihr das
wieder bewerten würde das zeigt mir dass
euch das ganze gefällt was ich hier
mache und dass ich eventuell öfter mal
dieses minecraft machen soll ich total
vergessen zu machen dass du einfach ganz
ganz doll bleibt ein großes herz an
allianz ein großes kammer 32 nicht alle
schreibt man alle klammer 32 in die
kommentare wenn ihr immer noch dabei
sein wenn die immer noch gerade am
zuschauen seit außerdem kann die mit
immer weiteren bieten die kommentare
schreiben
beziehungsweise dinge die ich die
eventuell andere leute noch nicht bei
minecraft wussten und wie immer eure
minecraft skins ich habe diesmal noch
kein skin genommen bei mainz kind dealer
programm
irgendwie noch geupdatet werden muss
dass ich die person des tages sollte er
da geht er ins feuern verbrennt
unglaublich gut wie immer freunde wieder
vom nächsten mal noch ein wunderschöner
tag rundschau